the haunting of Hell House has many
different things that can be taken from
its ending by the end of the show we are
all convinced that the experiences the
cranes have had are real and that the
house itself is a paranormal entity
hell-bent on making them suffer but what
if there's a completely plausible
explanation to the events that happen in
the show what if the one thing that is
present throughout is what is causing
the cranes to believe that they are
being haunted whilst we never get
concrete confirmation that this is the
case it seems completely likely that the
mold that Fester's throughout the house
may in fact be causing all of the
hallucinations and problems the black
mold is first found by the family in
Episode seven during which hue discovers
it spreading behind the walls of the
house
the father discusses how dangerous that
it is and stipulates that it can cause
problems both physically and mentally
the mold keeps them in the house for
longer than intended as Hugh knows that
he must fix it before listing it for
sale it could be concluded that the mold
is in fact causing all of the health and
hallucination problems that are rampant
throughout the family the red room
itself is heavily infested with a
massive amount of mold and this could
also be the reasoning behind this being
labeled as the houses stomach the red
room is considered to be the part of the
house where every problem resonates from
because it's completely filled with mold
the mold even makes an appearance in
Shirley's model house when it is found
in pieces
Shirley turns it over to find the inner
walls rotting with the black stuff this
could also be attributed as the cause of
the hallucinations that happen in her
home Luke witnesses the ghost of William
Hill outside of a mold infested area
however he is a drug addict and these
visions could be put down to the drugs
themselves even when Steve is painting
the little dresser for his mother we can
see hints of mold hidden below it when
he returns to the house in the show's
climax the ghost of Olivia informs him
that the other visions he has had of her
during his life are in fact all in his
head this showcases that he can still
hallucinate without there being in
for a ghost present maybe all of the
events in the show were brought on by
the black mold investing them what I
love about the show is that it works
either way the best ghost stories always
offer a way for skeptics to put the
events aside and whilst I do believe
that the apparitions were real it is fun
to consider that the may in fact not be
perhaps the family is as Steve States
suffering from a mental illness that was
brought on by the house infecting them
so do you think the ghosts in the
haunting of Hill House were real or do
you think the events were brought on by
the black mold comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video
please check out my full explanation on
the show which is linked at the end of
this one this is a channel for people
who are heavy into horror so if that's
the kind of thing you like hit subscribe
if you'd like to support the channel so
I can continue to create more content
like this and please donate to my
patreon which is linked in the
description thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
you
[Music]